I'm super attracted to the female
version of myself today we're going to
try the new immensely popular phone app
face app it provides digital technology
that changes your face to make you look
old young like a man or woman it is
blowing up on Instagram I'm sure you've
seen it how do you think you're gonna
look old I don't know I mean blacked out
crash so I might look the same oh oh
yeah this makes me scared to go I look
like a sad depressed alcoholic version
of my mom oh my god that's so goofy hey
I look horrifying old I'm like Barry
okay on seeing my cell phone I'm like
excited to be that guy you're supposed
to not want to age but I think a lot of
older women look beautiful
so I'm replacing young with
haha I don't even look human what
happened I look face - that's hell I
didn't change that much as its dude that
as a woman I became like an animation
character huge eyes a tiny nose giant
lips I think that's really unfair to
women that's not how most people look I
think that's an impossible standard and
I think it's also very racialized my
face doesn't look like a face it just
looks like some weird lighter material
that's just like been put on apparently
not attractive unless you own three
shades lighter than your birth time
have absolutely no signs of ever
existing it's creepy
I'm gonna see what I would look like as
a man whoa it looks almost exactly the
same Oh what is the difference between
you as you actually are and you as a man
according to this they really made no
genius you're like added freckles it's
such a weird thing to like make me more
males to add some freckles I'm not sure
why you get face at I'm not sure when
you do this to yourself I think this app
is [ __ ] sweet I'm happy being myself
more than ever after using this app I
think it's a fun app let's stop making
apps that make women feel bad about the
way they already look it's really fun
and entertaining this technology is
impressive itself
[Music]